the other things people remember of
campaigns
i pledge to be a president who seeks not
to divide
but unify the promises the pledges
the things to make a difference one
hundred days in joe biden has failed to
deliver
in a few key areas i think he's kept his
word as much as he can
i think people forget that there's not a
lot of legislating that can happen
from the presidential seat covered
relief was always his top priority
he promised two thousand dollar checks
to eligible americans
that became fourteen hundred dollars
under biden adding to the six hundred
delivered by trump
the death of journalist jamal khashoggi
provoked anger and then candidate biden
he promised to hold saudi arabia
responsible regard them as a pariah
state
fast forward to one month in office
saudi arabia was once again
a valuable ally all presidents
in these days talk about doing
a whole list of priorities on day one
but the idea that a president could
accomplish the types of promises that
they put forth on the trail
on day one is rather naive and
i would argue in some ways just part of
the marketing of campaign the promise to
immediately rejoin the iran nuclear deal
is also gathering dust
instead talks continue in vienna between
all the parties
about the best way forward real politic
instead of rhetoric joe biden also
promised to be a unifying president
pulling the country together after what
he felt were the divisive trump years
despite his early successes washington
is as divided as ever
we found out that trump is still here
trumpism is very much the politics of
the day on the republican side
and i think at least on the democratic
side there is no way that
they can see compromise with those kinds
of elements there
and so i think it's going to be a very
difficult road if he's going to pursue
bipartisanship at every step the good
news for joe biden
presidencies aren't judged solely on the
first 100 days
he gets the full four years but the next
election is never far away for biden
it's the midterms
next year it will be a referendum on the
job he's done till then
what he said he will deliver next and
the promises he's kept
alan fisher al jazeera washington